hello there reject nation I am Greg Alba
9 and John Humphrey one of our top of
war tears on patron whatever video
requests from spoon put up on YouTube
today comes from a named Chris Melia a
Canadian handsome man photographer yes
his own YouTube channel where he has a
segment there called nostalgia where he
basically revisits a video game that he
has already played really loves and does
a breakdown and commentary it's actually
really well edited really well scripted
I really really really enjoy those
videos you guys should definitely go
check it out
he did not ask me to plug that but I am
and the other thing is this video is
from his channel it's not part of that
nostalgia series he basically made this
video I'm assuming way way way before
endgame ever came out where he took the
song by MGK your boy how you gonna name
yourself after a gun when you got a man
yeah so he basically made this tribute
to Captain America it's called home and
he reloaded it on May 5th but this is
kind of an old video and you know if you
have seen any game I feel like oh yeah
it's good appropriate time to go watch a
tribute to Captain America right about
now dude I hope he doesn't spoil I'm
GK's cameo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know the lyrics really do match well
with that's right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice end it's gonna be well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah man if only you had end game
footage towards like that much more
perfect you got to release like a final
final yeah I gotta say I'm pretty
surprised by how well that song worked
especially when I really listen to the
lyrics and it put me in a mindset of
Captain America must be one of the
darker care I've always viewed it was
like the bright colourful Captain
America guy because he's the most
morally righteous one of them all sort
of upstanding and true
I wasn't like moved to tears here but I
felt my heart like little by little
breaking especially knowing what happens
an end game yeah you feel sad for cab
yeah with the end or the ending of end
game and watching the the lyrics of a
guy who just feels out of this world who
doesn't belong looking for a home
getting all this responsibility always
going up against evil it's basically
being a professional rap yeah the things
getting taken away from him constantly
being thrown into situations where he
feels divided it's like dude wakes up
from the ice and then is part of shield
and then a Winter Soldier finds out the
people he trusts he can't run like he's
constantly having his heart broken this
guy so I imagine even pay much yeah all
that stuff Abadi must be like one of the
darkest characters internally you know
but it's always struggling and always
having to put on the good fight and his
whole art being complete and endgame
made me love Captain America that much
more and maybe somehow watching this
video maybe just and would knowing
especially where a game goes I've like
to have this like much bigger
appreciation and understanding into
Captain America now because of this
video yeah and I feel like you kind of
hone in on the opposite side at least
while I took from the scenes you chose
you know is partly to the flip side of
the coin is that home is sort of the
battlefield for him you know yes at
least in the role that he's in he's like
the lead of the Avengers he essentially
lives his life for this right now at
least you know up until the events of
endgame and all that and so there is
that yin and yang of the emptiness of
not having an actual home and I
the actual like intimacy of family per
se but there's also the family found in
you know the Avengers as well as you
know his role you know protecting the
earth and all that stuff you said at the
beginning and your description box that
you wanted to get familiar with video
editing again before you hopped in
journey of style just series and this is
really well edited man like I thought
the way you mixed it with the beats
paying attention to the lyrics and
choosing the right imagery to match the
mood especially whenever you broke back
when the song broke back into the chorus
I thought you added to this very well
very specifically timed and every clip
felt calculated as to which one you
really want her to use it wasn't just
like this looks cool this fits you know
it seemed very specific and I really
appreciated this man thank you
yeah like thank you for let's do this
this is really all worth it I liked it a
lot helped me appreciate cap that oh
yeah a lot more I think I felt like I
have better insight into him alright
well you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation subscribe to Christmas may
you photography as well it's by how you
pronounce it
but I say mad yeah notification bells
are here check us on patreon John does
plenty of music video coverage over
there we do weekly Q&A is TV show
reaction stream along with some reaction
hi